questo 2023 non è stato assolutamente un
anno facile come un gomitolo di fili
tutti intrecciati tra paura insicurezze
pocoa autostima questi fili non si
snodano Oggi sono qui a dirvi che questo
2024 Regalerà emozioni perché noi ce lo
meritiamo Toro vergine e Ariete il 2024
è l'anno del sesso nessuno potrà
resistervi gente che va gente che viene
il cancro Leone acquario meno passione
ma una fortuna esagerata sopra la vostra
testa pioveranno milioni di euro in
gettoni d'oro bilancia sagittario e
Capricorno sono stati segni un po' più
penalizzati del 2023 acciacchi bronchiti
cataratte 2024 sarete energici
invincibili cogliete al volo questa
opportunità per scalare montagne vincere
gare olimpiche circum navigare la
Sicilia a nuoto gemelli Scorpione e
pesci le avete fatto il botto promozioni
lavorative eredit rete immobili ma
soprattutto troverete l'amore l'amore
vero con questo oroscopo meraviglioso Io
vi saluto Un bacio e un abbraccio alla
vostra astrom Mary Ciao